and then in 2017 i started again right
well and here the game is finally
starting magnus not visible yet do we
have the spanish opening we don't have
the spanish opening although
all of white's moves would be played if
it were a spanish opening instead though
black on the first move pushing
his sea pawn forward which means the
sicilian defense one of the most dynamic
openings in chess black often trying to
counter attack uh just creating some ill
imbalance with the pawns and talking of
pawn imbalances we've seen a pawn
sacrifice already it's only moved seven
white is upon down but look at black's
pawn structure it is weak and we
actually saw this early in the
tournament ivanka
in a clash between magnus carlson as
black and levon aronian that one ended
it up in a crazy game but fizzling out
to a draw eventually and uh this one jan
clearly having studied magnus's previous
game maybe he's come armed to
armed with an improvement armed with a
new idea to try and destabilize magnus
to try and throw him off meanwhile brave
from carlson to repeat exactly what he's
done before earlier in the tournament
yeah yeah very brave it just shows that
he's confident in his preparation and uh
the the newish move was uh actually
moving the rook to the santa attacking
one eyeing up the pawn and uh now moving
the knight to the edge of the board okay
that's not the most popular choice it's
been played before
yeah and white's compensation for the
pawn does lie in the fact that black's
pawn structure is just ugly and magnus
instead of trying to keep his pawns
guarded in the center of the board
giving the pawn back is that surprising
to you too
they're magnus just giving the pawn back
and okay jan establishing a strong white
knight in the center and magnus doing
the same with his own uh his own knight
and the white knights guarding each
other black finally castling
personally
i would be terrified of black's pawn
structure if you look at the c file
black has these two doubled pawns and
long term they are targets short term at
least
magnus has the two bishops
and the potential of those two bishops
might
long might later balance out
losing a pawn or at least having that
compromised structure it's uh quite
interesting no games have ever been
played in this particular variation but
of course it has been analyzed someone
had a look at it in 2019 another person
had a look at it in 2022 in january
though okay so uh
okay
and then the january analysis actually
runs with white developing the queen
diagonally one square
and uh after that they analyzed looking
at the the light squared bishop
developing all the way to the edge of
the board okay so the queen comes out
and then black's bishop comes out to put
some pressure on this knight this bishop
putting pressure on white's knight on an
outpost this bishop also putting
pressure on the other white knight in
the center and okay is yan freestyling
is he just um maybe has he studied this
before this is a bit of a strange move
that he's just played instead of
improving a piece such as bringing the
queen out to a very nice square lining
her up on this open file he just pushes
the pawn good strategy later because the
white king has some
pressure some breathing space but
not really changing
the position too much not really
activating his own pieces katrina in
general do you prefer having long-term
advantages like for example here white
having the better pawn structure or do
you prefer the power of the
bishops
ah i think that long term i would
struggle with having the double the
pawns just because i am not
very good at the end games
yet
and and so i would prefer to play white
in this position just because it looks
more
dynamic and easier to play but maybe
this is easier for magnus because he
knows what he's doing and
i think that also the long-term goal
maybe for
jan here is just pushing that pawn maybe
it is to prevent the bishop to coming up
yeah yeah no i think you're right
actually and the more i look at it for
example if black now pushes upon kicking
white's knight back black would love to
create this type of pin um just annoying
white snipe there but that has been
prevented by this innocent looking pawn
push so
yeah it's a real
i mean it's a really tense position
right now it's not clear who has the
advantage i don't think either side will
be thinking about the advantage but it's
just about whose plans are easier and uh
right now in the current position
these pawns just ugly magnus needs to uh
needs to activate his pieces quickly
otherwise white will be able to target
these guys the reason we say they're
ugly and weak is because they can't
defend each other and at some point
later we might see a plan such as white
pushing a pawn forward bringing the
bishop out and going for this front pawn
especially this front pawn is extremely
vulnerable
so okay let's go back to the players
it's
early days but as katrina mentions
magnus he's clearly studied something
similar to this before because he's
played it earlier in the tournament jan
may be less familiar with the ideas but
he must have studied it this morning
otherwise why else choose a line
like this one quite a rare variation and
it was a king spawn right kings one
opening yes yes and uh chess ball has a
sale on the king's pawn opening right
now so head down to chesable.com to
check out that sale and start practicing
your own kingsporn opening yeah and we
do have magnus back his camera is
working
and as ivanka mentioned this bishop
coming out putting some pressure on the
white knights i don't think either of
the black bishops actually want to trade
themselves off for the night that would
just be a fair exchange and
black needs to keep the long-term
potential of those bishops alive
meanwhile white going for that move as
well that has been played before has
been analyzed before bring the white
queen out just solidifying everything
white maybe is lagging behind slightly
in development because white's bishop if
you look on the first rank still at home
still at home asleep
so white still needs a couple of moves
to connect the rooks bring the rooks to
the center black does have access to
some open lines
this one i'm i'm excited i think it will
be similar to yesterday where
it's just imbalanced for a long long
time and then players will start to take
risks later in the game yeah and i do i
do agree with you david i think it is
kind of like white will be looking at
controlling the position and eventually
targeting those weak pawns and also just
maintaining um control over the light
squared bishop because that's the bishop
that's unopposed
and then black will just simply uh try
to sharpen things up you know because
they can't just sit there waiting so i
like the plan of i was going to say
kicking back the night
oh no now it looks like i cheated but
anyway i didn't
and the night retreats and then seizing
space
the player is playing incredibly quickly
here suddenly and uh napoli actually
true to style you know there's no
waiting with him that's why i noticed
from yesterday's games you know he just
you know he sees the plan and often if
he thinks it's good
he goes for it
um
i remember we had like all sorts of
subtle ideas
and
you know eventually doing something and
he was like no let's do it immediately
exactly trusting his instincts and
that's that's something that he lacked
or that he wasn't maybe
able to do in the world championship
match he was maybe thinking longer than
normal he was away from the board a lot
uh during the world championship just
kind of hiding in the the restroom just
kind of
maybe just not wanting to make that big
decision but
yeah this tournament he's been playing
instantly and it's been paying off for
him so
okay this last move by white's bishop
does attack that weak pawn that we
mentioned the front pawn of black's
double sea pawns
and okay magnus needs to either defend
it you could trade off the black knight
for that white bishop but then again
black's knight looks strong in the
middle yeah and uh yeah katrina are you
a quick player are you quite an
instinctive player or are you like me do
you just get bogged down into
all the decisions and become indecisive
i think i am
playing too quick of games
i don't do a lot of rapid games
and that's why
yes i think that that's why i don't get
into rook end games or end games in
general because i play too much splits
like i don't get to learn them
but here like getting the doubling of
the pawns do you think they would play
differently if it was a classical game
possibly
i have a feeling magnus would be
reluctant to play this type of opening
in classical games because as ivanka
mentioned white's idea is to keep
control it's easier to do that in long
games so if white is able to keep
control
later the weakness of the black pawns
would become the biggest factor in the
position maybe
but then again in rapid even if you lose
a pawn it's not the worst thing in the
world you just keep playing and you'll
get chances later anyway so
um yeah it definitely feels like this is
part of magnus's kind of speeches
repertoire
this opening
and okay meanwhile he did trade off
white's bishop i'm slightly surprised
but then again at least black's bishops
now are unchallenged on the diagonals
and if things do open up later they will
become strong for now though big threat
white's queen wants to go over and take
a black pawn one of those two double
pawns
yeah magnus the first one to take a
longer thinking break in this gaming
katrina
magnus became a world champion in 2013.
i remember myself living in norway that
the hype in norway was just incredible
everyone was staying home from work
during lunch watching the games in the
world championship match were you
affected by by that boom as well or did
your chess interests simply come later
it simply came later yeah i i'm really
sorry to say that i didn't start earlier
but that's how it is yeah i um
since i said in 2017 i didn't know much
of these players
like the international players besides
magnus because i saw him in the papers
all the time yeah but i think now that
i'm in the game i'm like
this is actually one of the best
communities i've been part of yeah
getting into the chess and it's so much
fun with this test has not been solved
you know so there's different challenges
every time they go to the board yeah and
do you have a favorite player is it
magnus being norwegian or do you have
someone else that you think is uh
entertaining to follow actually i would
say that um
judy pogba yeah i really like her games
and her
quickness when it comes to thinking i
really enjoy her when she plays and
maybe not so much anymore but i looked
at some of our games i have to think
they are really good yeah yeah so you
always say right david find a player
that you sort of want to play in their
style and follow those games yeah and
she plays really aggressive chess and uh
talking about aggressive chests i have
to take it back to the board because we
just saw magnus sacrifice the pawn right
david
yeah and uh that pawn offer was not
accepted by jan again
almost instantly in this position this
pawn is up for grabs magnus has just
moved his rook across this rook sliding
into the center of the board and the big
question would have been what happens if
white takes this pawn and to be honest i
think maybe he could have got away with
it maybe he could have been greedy i
guess magnus's idea by clearing this
square for his bishop on the last turn
moving his rook away is to slide back
hitting the white queen and when the
white queen moves i think she has to
retreat because the queen trade here
would allow a nasty double attack
hitting the rook hitting the knight so
if the white queen does retreat in this
position then magnus has ideas such as
pushing this pawn forward in the middle
of the board i'm not sure what order
maybe you could take the knight first
both are tempting but for example if you
take the knight and then push your pawn
in the center
yes white is a pawn up but now white is
the one with double pawns black gains a
bit of space gain some time against this
knight and wherever the knight moves the
pawns are starting to roll suddenly
black's pawns are moving fast down the
board and kaya likes her nice porn
structures this is a really well
fortified structure and
i think napoli actually just a bit too
frightened of this so he didn't get
greedy and uh if we catch up with the
game situation instead of taking this
pawn off the board he just dropped his
knight back maybe going after this pawn
with his knight and we actually see this
in the game black now finally defending
the spawn and the attack continues
against it with this knight maneuver so
a double attack
hitting this pawn with the knight and
with the queen
and uh magnus i think he has to bank on
just giving that pawn up at some point
and starting to push his central pawns
otherwise if you go too passive for
example if you drop your bishop back to
defend it black is just tied down and
top players they
hate being
passive in these types of positions so
okay he doesn't go back instead he
trades off and
now he does drop back okay slightly
surprising but then again at least he's
doubled the white pawns as well
really yes
complex position strategically yeah
definitely i was going to mention that
uh pawn structure take a look at their
sea lion have you ever seen
or poor double pawns and as we learned
from twitter thank you very much for
giving us this little rhyme double pawns
are troubled pawns yeah um
we have double trouble then
oh very good kyle it's like pokemon yeah
team rocket yeah
and now the rick comes to the open line
and uh i have to say that i was
i don't know whether i like uh magnus's
choice about giving up the bishop pearl
like this i mean i can see the the prose
to this you know you get that beautiful
pawn structure and it's coming
um but at the same time the knight is
the best placed weapon for a closed
position and this position is kind of
it's semi-closed i would say there's
only one open line and the knight is
going to be much more powerful than the
bishop yeah the bishop just tied down
indirectly defending its pawn it's going
to be stuck there for a long time and
you mentioned the one open line ivanka
napoleshi now is trying to dominate it
he's lifted his rook up the board and
we've talked about double bonds but
doubled rooks are even better if white
can double up his rooks then he might
try and break through on this file later
that's why magnus has to challenge for
the open file at some point he does so
immediately
and okay i'm just trying to work out
what happens here because rook takes
rook would force black to move either
his rook or his queen away and no matter
which piece you move away you will allow
white to take a pawn i think his idea is
to take with the rook if this happens
because now if white gets greedy and
catches in the center it looks like a
free pawn white can grab it but after a
trade you have to look and move further
every time you can't just stop here and
think white is just a pawn up you have
to look further and especially when it
comes to checks this is a check hitting
the white king the white king has
somewhere to run but suddenly at the
very end whoops there is a nasty pin the
black bishop wins the white rook next
move so magnus is setting a nasty trap
with that uh rook move he's just played
and uh okay now challenging for this key
file the d-file
that really would have been an oh dear
moment of uh what had fallen for that um
yeah i mean that's the type of variation
you look for first right and then you
realize it doesn't work for white and
then jan has to go back to square one
and just improve a piece as he does now
yep those rooks look nice yeah the white
rooks look very good they do look very
good um and now there is there is the
concrete threat of actually playing rook
takes rook and so this is why magnus
just improves his uh pawn structure
he's getting ready for the end game
he really is you know look at that
beautiful pawn chain and uh he's
lengthened the scope of his uh dark
square bishop which before was just
jammed in by his own pawns and uh i
think he's got his eye on that little
i think he's got his eye on a few things
one of the things i can think of is
maybe at some later stage is to
try to put the bishop on the longest
diagonal another idea that he
potentially has is to
try to push his a pawn alice up the
board and try to destabilize the white
knight but that comes with kind of risk
because once you push a pawn forward you
can't
take it back and then another thing is
just to maximize the pieces once all the
pieces get traded off i think magnus is
just playing on general terms if you
have a dark squared bishop you want your
pawns on light squares just so you can
control both color complexes so yeah
right now very tense position the
computer undecided about who has the
advantage 0.0 that doesn't mean it's
going to be a draw still a lot of life
left but it just shows both sides have
chances both sides have pros and cons
behind their position would you prefer
here katrina i'm struggling to decide
still white just because i would like to
have the four pawns there on
the queen side actually um
even if the two of them are double yeah
because black's pawns are also doubled
yeah and if you get your night moving i
think that nights can get really tricky
and maybe affect the back the
sea pawn that is like on the back rank
yeah i don't know if i would like being
blackier so it goes for trading off and
then going into quick end game yeah yeah
i'm slightly surprising because i'm
surprising surprise sorry uh because
white's queen has now stepped back so
black cannot challenge for this open
file anymore white has full control with
the white queen and rook
of this line
so
yeah it's
slightly surprising decision by magnus
maybe he wants to continue pushing on
the side he's stronger where black has
the four versus three advantage on the
right half of the board
that poor majority is quite mobile so it
can be pushed easily white's poor
majority however on the other side
a bit stuck and yeah your point katrina
about the double pawns um the difference
if we look on the c file black's double
pawns can't be defended by other pawns
they have to be defended by pieces
whereas white's double pawns can
actually be defended by other pawns as
well so they white's pawn mass over
there can defend each other um so
strategically white has an advantage
with pawn structure still
but uh there we go the white knight
getting involved and this is your idea
right yeah
attacking some pawns yeah
very uh
good to see that they are doing what i
am also thinking about
everything here so they're printing
rather quickly i think as well so
definitely look at yarn still 12 minutes
on the clock
but i've noticed that magnus is actually
copying this pattern as well because
he's like okay you know this is your
strong point you want to kind of
make me feel like i should be a little
bit intimidated i'm also going to play
quickly and i have to say i really do
love magnus's last moves last two moves
because he maximized the queen and then
he's actually maximized the rook and uh
like david mentioned
those pawns they're gonna start marching
and and uh i don't know
unless white can do something
on the left side he's going to be in a
bit of a pickle as we say in the uk
i don't know how that originated don't
ask me um but you know you can just see
that
that pawn is going to become past porn
maybe white's king is going to start to
get feel a little bit shaky and
yeah some real attacking ideas against
the white king actually one idea might
be to bring the bishop out and line it
up on this diagonal with the black queen
to try and sneak in towards the white
king that would be very very strong and
as ivanka mentioned just the brute force
approach the caveman approach would be
to just push pawns hope for the best and
white has to be careful uh if you try
and get active with the white queen
which is very tempting maybe jumping
into the position attacking some pawns
over here attacking this pawn with the
white knight then suddenly the white
queen has abandoned any defense of her
own king and black will start pushing
forward with his own pawns weakening
things up uh loosening the white king
and for example if if a capture happens
then now i would be very scared here uh
with white because suddenly checkmating
ideas with the queen
or by taking this pawn maybe as well
with a nasty check suddenly a lot of
threats against the white king
so yeah things are quite urgent here for
yanuponoshi it feels like he should be
okay somehow
just his knight could potentially be
very good but temporarily at least it's
not participating in the defense
and if he can't get active if he can't
win this pawn over the next few moves
then suddenly the trend might turn in
magnus's favor
yeah i agree with your banker this last
move
it's not obvious actually just defending
this pawn uh kind of abandoning the back
rank for black it's not a normal type of
move that we would see but very
effective by magnus and
i think we will we've already seen jan
spend two minutes i think we'll see him
spend even longer now because it is a
critical moment one slip and
black's attack might suddenly
get really scary i definitely um sorry
i'm sorry for kind of like having a big
smile on your face my face because when
david was sharing that line i had
simon's voice in my head going welcome
to the dangers
i couldn't shake it and so i just
started laughing
[Laughter]
what was the right uh lyrics highway to
the highway to the danger zone
not welcome to the danger zone but i i
kind of like welcome to the danger zone
better i think if it's welcome too well
is this welcome to the danger zone this
game is is is any of them feeling
worried right now you're talking about
the white king potentially being very
vulnerable yeah i mean the more i look
at the position the more i get worried
for white and i think it's the same for
jan he played super quickly up to this
point and then now investing over three
minutes
and i doubt we'll see a move over the
next minute or two because it is so
complicated i'm i'm looking and i don't
see a move that kind of gets that white
knight back involved towards the center
if you could pick up that white knight
and plant it in the center somewhere or
even on the king side uh maybe to attack
one of the attack black's rook then
white would be doing great but yeah that
white knight
not looking
like it's in its shining armor right now
just abandoned its own king and
magnus looking pretty chilled yeah and
look i've i noticed miners usually
drinks water he always has a bottle of
water but uh today it's something
different isn't it
could be water of course in that bottle
but maybe it was like some sort of soda
or something get some energy yeah it
could be some maybe an electrolyte drink
i've heard that that's quite popular i
remember when he was younger he always
thought he was always orange juice but
then he kind of consulted a professional
nutritionist and the nutritionist said
no no you've got to stay away from the
orange juice and the raisins because
this is going to give you a sugar spike
and that's why he kind of went to i
don't water i was going to say i don't
think he drinks coffee or tea no i think
we always just see the water yeah
it's the same in classical chess he very
rarely touches the hot drinks i think
coffee he's scared that the caffeine hit
will be at the wrong moment in the game
and that he'll have a bit of a dip
afterwards
and uh yeah i wonder if the nutritionist
advised him to eat the noodles which we
see nearly every day
on the champions chester
but yeah either way i think magnus will
be the happier of the two
and uh
okay there we go white pushes the pawn
again
pros and cons behind this last move
white's king has a bit more breathing
space but then again black's pawns maybe
have a target now this white pawn
stepping forward could be undermined by
some of the black pawns later in the
game
and the evaluation passed slightly over
to black side after this last move it
was a difficult situation though
napoleon actually had to find something
and
this one makes some sense i like the
fact he's kept his queen down here just
now if any of the black pawns advance
the white queen might be able to just
capture
so
yeah very very tense in this position
yeah looking on the ponyachi you can see
he actually did the exact same movement
as you david you were like oh pros and
cons with that and john did the same
thing you know it looks like he also
felt that okay it's an it's a good move
but i'm not 100 sure yeah and
for me that happens every time i play a
move in chess i'm just never sure
it looks good but it doesn't feel right
but yeah i think this
same stuff's going through yan's head
right now normally he's a very positive
player he doesn't show it in interviews
you see him shaking his head criticizing
his own play but ever since he was young
when i first met him i think he was nine
years old uh he was always
whenever you analyze with him he always
thinks he's winning he always sees the
positives in his own position but right
now there are definitely some negatives
as well that's why hence the
kind of maybe bobbing of the head yeah
but uh yeah also we talked about super
uh superstitions with jan's t-shirt uh
wearing it and playing so well the whole
tournament magnus yesterday started the
day with the white pieces he had a white
shirt today starting with the black
pieces flat shirt i don't know oh we saw
that in the world championship match
right about superstitions
what about your tie
yeah the chest tie um
partly it's become routine last season
of the champions chester always in the
final i whip out the tie
but also it's for peace today it's for
peace yes it's very nice do you also
have the chest socks
not today actually i left the flat and
as soon as i left the flat i realized i
forgot to wear them
next time next time yeah you still have
eight tournaments to go david eight
finals to go
to uh bring out the chess socks as well
all right well now it's uh magnus
carlsen in a pause thinking we did have
quite a lot of time trouble yesterday as
well yeah um understandable because the
games were just so so complicated and
really nervy for both sides i think
we're going to see the same today yeah
i'm surprised magnus is thinking right
now i would just start pushing some
pawns maybe towards the black king i
know exactly what simon williams would
do ginger gm he would pick up the black
h-pawn harry and march it down the board
because if you look at white pawn it's
covering the dark squares the white pawn
that has just pushed if you push harry
down the board a few squares two squares
two squares yeah and then push it again
next move you'll even if you if it comes
at the cost of a pawn you kind of
destabilize white structure you break up
the white pawns and this is just very
typical very thematic uh idea especially
once white has pushed this pawn the g
pawn forward in front of the king and uh
every time i've played simon williams as
soon as i touch my g pawn with white
with black
harry runs down the board and it's so
annoying i know it's coming but it's so
hard to deal with and especially in
rapid chess i think that would be quite
effective so yeah
i was also considering that move but i
also had a second move as a kind of
candidate as well and that was actually
moving the bishop one square so you know
we see this beautiful geometric pattern
on the sea line why not have it on the e
line as well now this and i wanted to
move my bishop there so it would be
bishop brook and queen and the idea the
idea is not to uh just appreciate the
beauty of chess on the board but it's
actually to push forward the g pull
okay yeah push this guy forward in order
to push the f ball forward in order to
push the e forward it's like sounds like
a good rhyme there yeah
what happens if you push the g pawn now
yeah i think black would love to do this
but at the moment it could be captured i
guess queen takes porn would be a check
your idea katrina maybe to slide the
rook across yeah yeah to go for the
white queen actually this is really that
is dangerous actually
nice katrina yeah giving up a pawn but
sometimes pawns aren't so important now
the rook on the same file as the white
king the white queen has to budge if she
goes to a bad square for example if
she's okay he challenges the white queen
but i like this now you start rolling
with the pawns yeah maybe magnus saw
something like this maybe he was
calculating it for the last couple of
minutes but um yeah risky for both sides
i guess and he's played a slightly safer
move uh in the end magnus instead of
going for this which actually the more i
look at it the more i like it uh magnus
sliding his rook across hitting the
white queen and we do see a rook trade
wow okay i knew i think in general a
rook trade favors white because black's
pawns are going to come become even
weaker now the black crook is off the
board unable to defend them but magnus
has a specific idea in mind he's pushing
forward he's trying to break through to
the white king even with rooks off the
board uh the white king might become a
big target
and i don't think you can really allow
this pawn to much forward two squares
away from its end goal but you might
have to because if pawn takes pawn then
black won't take this guy
black will take the other pawn instead
with a check and suddenly everything
falls with check this king has to move
if you go to the corner check if you
move check every pawn falls and black is
simply winning so really really
dangerous position here for uh yandere
pognishi
maybe you have to stop this pawn with
your king
i think you have to stop it either with
your queen blockading right now or you
have to step your king across to stop
its advance either way uh magnus
setting some real problems for jana
panishi
yeah uh definitely white already
in a little bit of danger and uh i think
the move the two moves that you highly
highlighted are totally vital i mean i
can't see anything else i mean
if you allow that pawn one square fell
forward it's just because it's gonna be
a game over right and especially because
the promotion squares on a dark square
the same color as the bishop which kind
of might seem elementary but these are
the things that do help you when you're
making those assessments and he has
stopped that pawn by moving his queen
so why didn't he take it with his pawn
yeah so taking this pawn would have
allowed the black queen to pounce and
take this guy and suddenly all of the
white pawns are weak this is a check and
these two white pawns will also drop off
over the next couple of turns
so yeah you couldn't open up your king
yet
jan is saying okay you can open the king
but it's on his terms
and with this queen move blockading
black's pawn now if we see black's pawn
capture then white will simply take back
with the king and actually everything's
defended a queen trade doesn't favor
black because
the pawns will just oh sorry the pawns
will just drop off a bit later on and uh
meanwhile the white king protects the
queen and protects this pawn
that would all be fine for white so
magnus says okay let's keep that tension
bringing his bishop into the game and
wow just giving up a pawn even uh if
this pawn is captured i think magnus's
idea is to maybe try and trap this
knight
you could do that i mean firstly you can
step into the centre of the board but
i'm wondering where the escape square is
if the queen drops back
maybe this knight is just trapped yeah i
mean maybe you could also attack the
knight from another square on the d line
and then
try to try to come in with your queen
and
this looks even stronger maybe bring the
queen in now and uh yeah suddenly white
is going to be overwhelmed if a queen
trade happens this pawn becomes a new
queen
so dangerous still for yan napongishi so
the bar is just uh the 0.0 all the way
in the middle
but i play
but i'm sensing on you guys that this
could be dramatic and especially for
yonder pontiac yeah totally one wrong
move and we saw it yesterday you know
when the players kept blundering you
know one bad move changed the whole
nature of the game and suddenly you know
chess is like that
life can be unfair chess is on at times
and uh yeah i mean here napomiashi
decides that okay let's retreat the
night so let's try to get that into the
action
but
okay
i always try to look at the consequences
of each move that's been played i mean
knights are just great defenders and i
think he's trying to rush that knight
back uh in case it needs to defend its
king
and uh yeah this is the type of position
we could see the evaluation bar if jan
does make a slip just shoot off and be
completely winning for black i don't
think meanwhile we'll see it go the
other way uh not so drastically at least
it might go for a slight advantage to
white if white is able for example to
take the queens off or at least survive
this incoming attack then okay the
attack continues ones are marching
forward and yeah just trying to open the
white king this is consistent
yan meanwhile frowning i'm not sure
whether he's frowning because he doesn't
like his position
i wouldn't like white's position or
maybe he's just confused uh by this last
move maybe he was expecting something
different but
would you be scared here katrina ah
yeah that's why definitely and i i
wanted to also mention that like the boy
is saying that it's a dead strong if
they play this right but
for me playing this psychologically that
would be really tough because it looks
so hard like when you're having your
black pawns coming into your king's area
and then there's still a queen on the
board i feel that this is really
threatening for among us yeah yeah i
think you're right it's psychology here
and uh
yeah computers they'll defend perfectly
of course they're cold-blooded but yeah
for a human pawns marching in your face
white is the one retreating white's
knight had to come back from where it
just jumped to a few moves ago white had
to find pretty much an only move or one
of the only moves with that queen
blockade earlier now the black bishop
getting active
yeah you're completely right this is
scary still for white now the white king
is very open right yep it's lost its
clothes yeah lots it's lost its
bodyguards those white pawns the white
porn shelter completely destroyed but
then again white's queen will act as a
good defender any checks that come she
will blockade
so
yeah it feels so dangerous for white but
maybe jan still has things under control
for now and if he does treat queens
things might turn back in white's favor
okay so he's definitely going to try to
trade the queens yeah okay because his
king is in danger and when your king is
in danger it's it's almost always a good
rule of thumb to swap off queens writing
it down yeah because the queen is the
most a dangerous attacking piece so yeah
try and trade off the queens yeah
because if you look at this position
white queen will never be anything more
than a defender black's queen could do
everything pretty much also queens are
best right in this i mean most pieces
are best right in the center of the
board but especially queens
because look how many squares the black
queen covers on the queen side king side
i mean vertically horizontally the black
queen covers everything white queen now
getting ready to maybe offer a trade
also staring at some of the black pawns
and uh magnus will he push harry finally
i'm waiting for that move to arrive i'm
waiting for that as well because i i
really do think that uh magnus has to
bank on the fact that the white knight
is out of out of play it's offside and
instead he needs to initiate play on the
right side because that's where he's
strongest
exactly actually if you look at the
positioning of the two pieces black's
bishop completely dominates the white
knight in terms of the white knight
retreating and
jumping over to the other side of the
board that's why a lot of top ground
masters prefer the bishops just because
they can control the knights it's very
rare to see a knight completely dominate
a bishop sometimes it happens depending
on the pawn structure but bishops
regularly um
i mean they control both sides of the
board they can dominate a knight
okay
right now magnus down on the clock
he needs to decide does he go and defend
the pawn that white's queen is attacking
on the diagonal he drops his bishop back
clever move maybe because now if white's
queen gets greedy and goes and captures
a black horn on the left side of the
board the black queen will come down and
create some nuisance
and well
napoli actually showing that you know if
your position is bad you might as well
go for material and he's moved his
knight to the edge and finally the bar
reacts yeah it doesn't doesn't quite
like it
i mean it just feels inconsistent from
napolite earlier he moved his knight to
this square a few minutes later he moved
it back then he moved back again he has
won a pawn however
white is a pawn up
but the checks have begun white's king
will it survive this onslaught
you can block it with your queen this
check
or you can move the white king away
big decision for napoli actually i don't
think black is risking anything because
at the very least there'll be checks
forever uh you can probably repeat the
position with some checks later on
but either way um
yeah magnus trying to sneak towards that
white king i was thinking you know look
it with the queen this is choices
choices or run away with the king i'm
just
i'm just working it out i'm just
thinking maybe you have to block it with
the queen
to first of all attack the dark square
bishop and maybe give some air for your
king to run if necessary
yeah yeah so if the white queen moves
and blocks uh this check uh we're
expecting it to go to the light square
then at least the white king can use the
square that the white queen's currently
sits on to run towards the center i
don't think the white king's gonna be
entirely safe on the back rank on the
first row and now we see it the computer
confirms the queen block was by far the
best move now things are all in black's
favor
wow
i mean such a tight rope to walk
i mean finding only moves in this
position is incredibly hard white had
three or four well three options there
he chose the wrong one though and now
this check
blocked by white's queen
can magnus continue
can he press this advantage it's still
not clear to be honest from a human
point of view exactly how to punish
white
you could give a check from the black
queen you definitely don't want to trade
off now the queen's whites are pawn up
so you could bring the black queen back
actually park it next to the white
knight and check the white king on the
diagonal that's one option
i mean
for me i i'm struggling to see anything
else to be honest yeah i'm struggling to
see anything else like i saw an almost
checkmate but it didn't quite happen
they almost checked mates i would need
my black pawn to mysteriously appear on
a different square on g4
and then i could have like a nice bishop
check but that that's kind of like
dreamlander
you can show this actually uh maybe so
right now it doesn't quite work but if
black had this extra move of having this
pawn on this square maybe he'll try and
repeat the moves and then flick his pawn
to this square later but if the pawn was
there for example just to show you
vancouver's idea a bishop check drawing
out the white king luring it out in the
open and this would be a nice pretty
checkmate
uh the kiss of death checkmate
is that what it's called no it's called
something else but i can't remember
all checkmates have a name and uh i
think it's called the code
i've forgotten how are you with your
checkmates katrina in your games do you
often go all the way to checkmate yes
yeah
somebody told me that like since we are
new into chess uh you should go the
entire game and see how it goes because
especially when it comes to classic
games you can learn from your positions
when you get to the end game even though
you're losing maybe you learn how the
rooks work together or maybe the pawns
are some strategies you can learn about
and i think it's it's important for
especially us new players to do this
plus it's entertaining to see those
checkmates okay what's going on okay
we've just seen magnus repeat the
position i don't think he wants to go
for the draw i think he's just gaining
time on the clock because he is down to
around a minute now but this is the
second time we've seen this position if
the black queen jumps down to the first
rank and gives another check and then
goes back where she came from it's just
going to be a draw
magnus i think he can still use his
bishop but there is risk involved and
he's low on the clock is he going to
bail out
play it safe now with black or is he
going to press for the win
he does play for the win not the move we
expected just taking a timeout defending
his pawn keeping it on a safe square but
ivanka you thought that was better i i
thought that he was actually going to
step his bishop one square forward and
try to kind of box the king in some
mating of a net but uh
no
now the white queen sliding across now
she has some threats she wants to go up
to the middle of the board check the
black king and trade off the queens
maybe just giving white this one move of
respite one move uh has just changed
things because now how do you trap that
white king the white king has a run a
path out into the open again
so
okay maybe magnus missing a big
opportunity there and frowning look at
magnus just not too happy
shaking his head as well he i think he
just felt his instincts would have told
him there was a good move there i mean
often in these positions especially with
queens on the board you see so many
different checks you see so many
different options it's hard with one
minute to work them all out and he would
have known there was something in the
position but he just didn't have enough
time to find it
and there we go white's king stepping
out of the check
does jan have winning chances as well or
is he only trying to save a draw
if magnus pushes too hard if the queen's
come off yan has great winning chances
but
it looks like magnus now having [ __ ]
having let things slip having shaken his
head he's going to try and escape from
this position with a draw this is the
second time we've seen this position as
well we've seen the players repeat once
if black's queen goes back and gives a
check we're going to see a draw white's
king stepping into the corner there we
go first result of the day wow it's a
quite
long game 46 moves they played for 45
minutes